this thing about the Titanic five these
guys talking about a race for time
they're down there they're possibly we
don't know if they're still alive we
have no idea if they're alive right now
everyone that I know is talking about
this situation right now but you know
what's interesting and and Sheamus you
and I were talking before uh we got on
air about this there were people who are
rooting for them to die yep there are
people who are rooting for the ocean in
this situation and look I'm gonna be
honest I'll say this with you know I
don't wear in the beanie right now but
with my my former you have a friend
named Jack I have a friend named his
name poso who's a former Navy officer uh
these guys are in Miracle territory
they're in they're in Hail Mary
territory at this point it's it is it is
not likely right now that they will be
saved uh due to a number of factors the
severe and extreme depth that the
Titanic is at the fact that this thing
has as far as we know has not surfaced
uh they have an emergency procedure
where it can resurface very quickly it
doesn't appear to have done that uh it's
the same some kind of damage
um there's been questions about the
whole uh integrity and if the hull is
breached I mean it's they've been done
the whole time yeah exactly as far as we
know um there's no way you any human can
survive at that depth and certainly not
at that pressure you'd be you'd be
killed instantly basically if the whole
there was a whole breach
um that being said even if there wasn't
to be able to find this thing get some
mercibles down there it's you you just
don't have enough time you don't have
enough air but what is going on where
there are people who say well these guys
are rich you know what they get what
they deserve and I think we talked about
it before and serge you at the point as
well we're always told we're always told
that oh we're we don't hate the rich we
just love the poor so much they're
exploiting the poor we just love the
poor really because I you can go and
look up I think it's called the Titan
you can look up the Titan type it in
Twitter right now and you will see
people arguing and cheering celebrating
the fact that they want these people to
die now and getting thousands of likes
and it's everywhere and I don't it's not
friends you know I don't necessarily
think that these guys are you know
Heroes I don't know if they're that
they're exp they're not Lewis and Clark
okay they're not they're not Magellan
yeah um yeah there's people that have
that have pioneered these areas before
they are they taking a risk yes it is a
foolhardy risk I would say probably
um but that being said they're human
beings yeah and they have families and
and to say that because this person is
wealthy I hate them and I'm going to
celebrate their death as an absolutely
sick thing to say it shows you exactly
how hateful they are I'm gonna quote
somebody I I saw a tweet from an account
called good tweetman and what he said
was
all of the people who are saying they
hope these people died and rooting for
them having a horrible death of the same
people who say
um I just want everyone to have health
care that's my form of extremism and
it's true now this just goes to show you
that the vast majority of people who
call themselves socialists or leftists
are in truth envious
they want to tear people down who have
more than them they want to see people
who have more than them suffer and even
die there's there's a very intense
Darkness here even though they claim
that they don't hate these people now
conservatives for example will be
accused of hating gay people basically
all the time if I heard a group of gay
people died in a submersible or in some
other horrible way I wouldn't be going
oh this is wonderful I don't I don't
cheer for the deaths of people whose
choices I disagree with and who I don't
like like my desire for people if I
think they're doing something wrong is
for them to repent turn to God have a
good life and get to heaven
die to go and sin no more and repent not
to die a horrible death so anyone who
who makes a claim like this anyone who
says that it's good that these people
died they've lost the moral High ground
but to be fair most of them lost the
moral High Ground long ago and their
world view is about hatred anger and
I'll leave you with this
most of the time when people are calling
for equality with their actual what
they're actually calling for is a
celebration of themselves in their own
aggrandizement because it's very rare
that somebody's calling for equality is
actually doing the work to help people
who are beneath them in terms of wealth
or social status they're almost always
looking to the people who are higher
than them and saying it is criminal that
I'm not on their level that they occupy
a higher position than me everything
that we were saying about Pride earlier
these are prideful people who are saying
any system that doesn't Place me at the
top is one which is fundamentally
corrupt and so I will celebrate when
people who are above me die which is
also which is also Envy Ian I want to
get your take because we got to get you
in the conversation here a little bit
more look I know you've been you've been
you've been crunching the numbers you're
looking at the submersible you've got
the Science Background what would be the
Ian Crossland way to try to get this sub
up oh man deep sea lasers
um like laseroscopy some some way to map
the the vibrations of of it is so small
and the ocean is so huge and currents
take you so fast we were watching these
jet stream currents that things can get
caught up in they lost contact with the
mothership these things aren't
submarines they're submersibles they
can't go under alone so they've lost
contact at 45 minutes 45 minutes it was
going to take them two hours to get down
and at 45 minutes I thought it was an
hour and a half so as you said is it
only two hours to get down I thought it
was like eight I didn't realize okay
maybe two and a half I think I saw two
and a half so really okay it was only it
was before they were even reached the
bottom that they that they disappeared
off off contact so that was like I don't
know Sunday Saturday yes and then I
think I think the hour and a half was
the final uh distress call an hour and a
half was a final distress call
purportedly they've got another 12 hours
of oxygen on board
um but that's assuming that there hasn't
been a great breach a hall breach I
don't know if they're hooked on the
Titanic somewhere if they're caught in
algae if they're on a net if they got
washed away and they're stuck under a
rock somewhere seven miles away they
they could actually be you know they
could actually be inside the Titanic
because there was a a story that someone
else this is not the first voyage of
this sub and they there was a guy who
said that when they went down the last
time they actually essentially landed on
the deck of the Titanic look this
thing's been down there for a hundred
years if you're trying to land on the
attack of something Crush under that
pressure wasn't designed to operate at
that pressure at the surface level it's
a surface ship
um there's a there's a it's kind of
black humor but saying it now but uh
there's a there's a line in the in the
Navy that every ship can be a submarine
once it's kind of like how the
ukrainians found out that any any
vehicle can be a Minesweeper once
um in the current counter-offensive
um yeah so there's that
um but they could have they could have
been attempting another one of these
Landings to say hey we're on the deck of
the Titanic and then believe it or not
we could actually be seeing an increase
in the death toll of the Titanic itself
well but then the question is if that's
a realistic possibility I mean why
haven't they been searching there or why
haven't they looked there I mean I
imagine it's difficult to get a
submersive
or that being said it could just be
because uh just because of the severe
depth uh again that's okay Navy hat back
on uh you can't you can't just get one
of these submersibles there on station
immediately it's not like you know it's
not a Marvel movie it's not the Avengers
the plane doesn't just like fly in from
you know the across the skies and then
everyone just flies down to the bottom
of the CEO you have to get it you have
to spin it up you have to get it powered
you have to get it set you have to dial
in the parameters for where you're going
you have to get it on station
um you can't just fly something out and
drop it in typically you need a ship
tender for one of these things uh so you
need another ship that needs to be
prepared then that ship has to go out at
ship speed so you're talking about 10
hours 12 hours just to get on station
once you've got the the remote operated
vessel that's there remember every
vehicle that's on station so I mean
you're you're fighting against the clock
the entire time the ocean is massive uh
this is way way down and it's possible
well that even if they have something
down there they have no clue exactly
what was going on and well the
controller disconnected right yeah the
thing was done it was controlled by a
Logitech controller that's insane look
at the video game controller video game
controller thirty dollars Logitech stock
took a hit I was reading okay as soon as
soon as I um I heard about this story my
conspiracy had came back on and I was
like dude the Titanic is still taking
down billionaires because I'm sure you
guys have probably heard that like yeah
about people on the Titanic uh initially
were like Bankers that didn't want to do
the Federal Reserve John Astor was one
of them I think right yeah and then
that's where you know Jekyll Island and
the bankers there and then that's when
they started the Federal Reserve oh here
we go
by the way by the way I just saw on on
Daily Mail real quick right real quick
on Daily Mail that I saw one of the and
one of the members of the current crew
the Titanic five that's on there right
now are actually descendants of people
who died on the original
well they wanted to see how you know
their their ancestor died that's a sad
thing they're going to explore the sight
of where a family member died now
they've very well may die and and you
know people uh on the left think that's
wonderful so
I will I'll ask you this at the depth
that they were lost about 45 minutes in
is is one contact was lost
okay so my question for you is
approximately what depth would they be
at at that point do you have a good
answer for that or is that sort of
outside of your you'd be at least a
couple hundred feet down okay so then my
question is if not a couple thousand
yeah yeah what could happen at that
depth I mean would this just have been a
problem with the submersible itself or
are there currents that could come sweep
you away very quickly all of the above
okay thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time